[Music]
in our new
normal series we're looking at how the
coronavirus is changing our everyday
lives
this morning how the pandemic is taking
a bite out of american favorites the
hamburger
beef prices are up 20 percent since
february the meat industry was hit hard
when the virus sickened thousands of
workers at packing plants
those higher prices have opened the door
for plant-based meat alternatives
barry peterson shows us the battle
stretching from the heartland
to your local supermarket
under an endless wyoming sky mark isley
and his daughters
are calling in the cattle owner of the
king ranch company
and a rancher for 50 years iceland has
survived droughts
economic downturns even blizzard but the
pandemic has wreaked havoc on packing
plants
causing shortages and concerns how
nervous are you mark about coping with
the coronavirus these next few months
financially will be challenged do you
think it's uh
going to get more expensive for
consumers it probably will for a little
while i hate to say that but i imagine
it's supply and demand
and where the bottlenecks will be
affecting it higher prices
and fewer beef cuts in grocery stores
have created a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
for his competitors the makers of meat
substitutes
meat tastes pretty good right so so
let's go ahead and build it from plants
hey there ethan brown is the founder and
ceo of beyond meat
a plant-based alternative created in a
lab
he's battling for a bigger share of the
market
we now have an opportunity to be price
competitive
with beef with respect to our burgers
and so we're taking that opportunity in
this summer we're going to be very
aggressive on our pricing
in this david versus goliath competition
for consumers
beef is a 67 billion dollar business
but since the onset of the virus sales
of fresh meat alternatives
have more than doubled from a year ago
vegan soul food is one of the hottest
trends
in soul food right now adrian miller is
an award-winning food writer and
barbecue competition judge i think if
they can get the cost down
and then do effective promotion to
different communities
i think it could really take off i've
had several
plant-based burgers and they're pretty
good
my son wants to know what's most
important i tell him my job is to look
out for the next generation
beyond meat created a campaign with some
of their celebrity investors including
chris paul and kevin hart and for summer
barbecues
a value pack of beyond burger sales at a
suggested price of
640 per pound narrowing the gap to beef
patties
which are around 5.65 a pound
this cattleman for one isn't buying
everything in here is highly processed
and i think that's my biggest problem
with it
which to you says not as healthy not as
healthy
nothing not even close my father's 86 my
mother's 85.
that's been the staple of their diet for
their entire life
i would like to do as well and follow
right in their footsteps
if you're having animal protein three
times a day and consuming
a lot of processed meat and red meat i
think the literature is pretty clear
on the health implications of that so i
think it would be misguided to say
that that's what's causing their
potential longevity
on the ranch eisley took me for a ride
in his 1928
model a ford almost as old as the ranch
itself
this was the new technology of its time
but brown thinks the model a tells
a different story about his new
technology
henry ford didn't go around saying that
you know the horse is the source of all
evils and wrongs in the world just
created a better way to get from point a
to b
if you think that way you can win
consumers over because they also want
something better
i think beef will continue to sell i
think it will continue to be popular
whether faux meat is a fad or part of a
new normal
as summer continues to sizzle the battle
for your dollars will stretch
from the prairie to the dinner plate for
cbs this morning barry peterson west of
cheyenne wyoming hold on a second barry
gets to ride the classic car
and ride the horse during the story and
you probably and of course turns into a
great story again as usual
yeah it's all about tasting these right
because some of the plant-based burgers
are really bad
right some of them taste better yeah i
actually had my first
vegetarian hot dog last week how was it
oh boy i like the impossible waffle it's
good i'll have to try that one